it's Black History Month so one month of
the year where we all get together and
talk about race and how we've pretty
much fixed it but the social justice
warriors will walk explain to you that
this month is a time for me to learn
something listen and take a back seat
it's not gonna happen I'm not taking a
back seat I have to sit up front because
I get motion sickness moving forward
makes me puke it's very common ailment
for people like me so riding shotgun
with me is Kobe LeMay I'm here to bring
attention to an important cause out
there BLM well are you talking about
black lives matter oh god no not some
militant radical I'm talking about BLM
black lives manners because as we all
know there is an epidemic of
impoliteness in the black community and
it could easily turn into a case of
systemic rudeness the black the black
lives manners movement has its roots in
the Jim Crow era where if you were
impolite to white people you were
scolded with murder
and to make sure I'm up on the good
etiquette I check in with televisions
home for Black History Month fox news
these guys just don't see race until
they do and then immediately become an
authority on it I should know I went to
Fox News finishing school so like many
black men in America I'm virtually
finished yeah
is it the mascot over there the fighting
status quo yes indeed and all across Fox
News they're taking advantage of this
month to really listen to themselves
telling black people how to act after
the State of the Union
Geraldo had some really helpful advice
for the Congressional Black Caucus
everybody's parents teach them manners
manners are very simple how can you not
cheer if you are a member of the
Congressional Black Caucus for historic
low black and and Latino unemployment I
mean that's a that's an applause land I
don't care who says it sure he looks
like if Willy Wonka ran a tanning salon
but he makes a great point if it's an
applause line you applaud so what if
Donald Trump mildly supported some tiki
torch white nationalists he still said
one nice thing in his speech say Jack
the Ripper gave a state of the
serial-killer address saying sex worker
wages are on the rise the women he left
alive Oh him a standing ovation that's
just good manners yes yes yes yes it is
it's all about doesn't stop there let's
jump over to Laura Ingraham Fox News
rich on to the picnic she saw that
congresswoman Maxine Waters gave a
response to Trump's speech and she just
knew that she had to offer a helping
hand
give us the angle Ingram Beatty featured
a response to the State of the Union a
day after the state of the year whenever
he appears on TV there should be a
disclaimer that says this may not be
acceptable for children first of all it
was Maxine Waters did a child make the
backdrop for that said what was that
nothing says you're seriously engaging
with someone's ideas like criticizing
their camera backdrop yes
exactly and laura is an expert on
backdrops her show really captured the
feeling of living inside a game of
off-brand Tetris see Maxine's crime is
she's no fun black manners dictate that
if you want to participate in the public
discourse you need to be either fun or
grateful and ideally both like free
Scientology Will Smith exactly Jordan
but if black people don't speak in a
humble accessible way the rest of
America won't hear them just listen to
Greg Gutfeld if you look up a lie in the
urban dictionary you'll find Greg he's
been laser focused on the issue of NFL
players kneeling during the national
anthem now everyone knows that started
as a protest against police brutality
but Greg does a great job of also not
knowing it the dealing stuff was poorly
articulated nobody really knew what it
meant that it had people have to keep
repeating it over and over again and it
became a question to patriotism not a
question of brutality yes they had to
say it so many times as if no one cared
to listen and because players weren't
being articulate to the good people at
FoxNews had to grab the bullhorn and
tell the protesters what they're really
protesting can you believe that the
disrespect for our country our flag our
anthem continues without penalty to the
players
Kaepernick disrespects the national
anthem disrespect for the flag
disrespecting our anthem disrespect our
troops if you listen close you can hear
these commentators beating us over the
head with the idea of disrespect
where are the manners protesters that's
systemic rudeness these protests are
just so disruptive when all I'm trying
to do is have a good time not
considering what they're about and you
should be able to enjoy yourself the
black lives matter movement is all about
keeping black people alive while the
black lives manners movement is all
about keeping white people comfortable
because if you study American history
you'll notice that white comfort has
always been more important than black
lives and Fox News knows that so let's
not rock the boat even if the boat is
carrying slaves on a horrifying journey
to America
well I got Toby I I would say I
certainly don't feel white comfortable
right now
oh don't worry Jordan Black History
Month is practically over already
February is basically a week yeah I
think we can have this whole race thing
wrapped up by March oh yes no and it's
called white March Jordan the month we
focus on all the great white marches
that will no doubt be happening in
response to Black History Month